[Music]
Kim Kardashian and Mariah Carey crashed
their daughter's Tick Tock and it is
everything isn't that exciting on Monday
Kim and Kanye West's nine-year-old
daughter North and Mariah and Nick
Cannon's 11 year old daughter Monroe
shared this clip to Kim and North's
joint Tick Tock account
that's the deal singing and dancing to
Mariah's song It's A Wrap before their
famous moms enter the frame singing into
hairbrushes
I don't know how you're gonna top that
the caption it's a wrap but never for us
yeah Bible of course North has famously
crashed a lot of her mom's videos over
the years having kids is just there's no
way to describe it but it's a lot back
in 2020 Kim's little girl totally bombed
her PSA about social distancing amid the
coronavirus pandemic hi everyone in
California it's Kim Kardashian West and
I just wanted to talk to you and
Northwest I know that can you not jump
on the bed give me like two seconds to
seriously do this oh and let's not
forget this classic moment I'm hiding in
the guest room you guys I'm hiding in
the guest room because my kids
will not leave me alone hey that's mean
so we kind of love seeing Kim turn the
tables
but that isn't the only Tick Tock North
and Monroe made the two gave a special
tribute to Rihanna Monroe dressed in red
to match the singer's Super Bowl
halftime performance and North rocking
white just like ree's backup dancers
so cute they captioned the clip We Love
You Rihanna oh thank you this is just
the latest headline making Tick Tock
from North who launched her account in
2021 but has been making videos in
secret since 2020. North has a private
Tick Tock account so we we do lots of
tick tocks together and she puts them in
drafts she's not allowed to post them
but we have lots of tick tocks I might
post one soon in January North used
makeup to transform into her
grammy-winning dad for this place
[Music]
she definitely loves makeup her new
favorite thing ever is no one in the
room no adults closing the door with one
of her friends or her dolls and doing
makeovers and no one can see until the
final look is done or she'll freak out
and cry she loves a before and after and
North recently proved she has Mad art
skills too sketching her grandma Kris
Jenner and brother song it's really
special whether it's a pencil sketch a
makeover or a lip syncing with a cameo
from Kim and Mariah one thing's for sure
no one does tick tock better than North
the world